o sea el análisis con gustavo neffa
director de research for traders
economista y profesora de finanzas en
buenos aires argentina gustavo gracias a
usted era de esperarse esta decisión de
rusia de exigir rublos dado que sus
operaciones en otras monedas han sido
bloqueadas por sanciones occidentales
funcionará esta estrategia de putin para
no desabastecer a rusia
bueno es una de las herramientas de las
pocas herramientas que tiene rusia como
para poder permitir
depender menos de los dólares y esquivar
las sanciones financieras impuestas por
occidente básicamente por lo tanto el
problema es que está rusia es el segundo
productor mundial de gas natural y
exporta el 78 por ciento del gas natural
a europa
por lo tanto europa es dependiente y es
un problema para europa estas tensiones
sobre todo para algunos países sobre
todo alemania y en menor medida italia y
sobre todo algunos países en el norte de
europa que dependen excesivamente más
del 60% de su matriz energética de gas
natural del gas ruso eso es una de las
alternativas que tiene el régimen de
izquierda de moscú como para qué
y pueda depender menos de las sanciones
pero en definitiva los mercados
internacionales se operan en dólares va
a ser difícil que los socios y sobre
todo los enemigos acepten las decisiones
de moscú bueno pero entonces sé qué
opciones le queda a europa que sabemos
es tan dependiente como usted lo dice de
combustible ruso especialmente del gas y
que pasará por ejemplo con el caso de
alemania que es uno de los más afectados
bueno hay que tomar en cuenta lo que
pasó en el 2014
en la elección a crimea por parte de
rusia nunca dejó de bombear petróleo
rusia a europa ni siquiera ni siquiera
la unión soviética dejó de bombear el
gobierno natural a europa en la guerra
fría con lo cual hay intereses
económicos detrás que quizás no
entendemos o en los cuales hay contratos
que se van a terminar cumpliendo más
allá de la guerra acá lo que hay es un
cambio de moneda que instruye putin para
gazprom y gazprom baje a sus clientes
para cambiar los contratos va a ser
difícil también porque todo esto puede
ser parte de un gran litigio posterior
ahora decir el kremlin se va metiendo en
problemas día tras día a medida que van
apareciendo las sanciones y se hace
empezar sobre la economía va a ser muy
difícil que rusia imponga su decisión
sobre todos los n
y
lograrlo en otros países pero no con
occidente bueno y brevemente qué
implicaciones tendría usar el rublo que
actualmente está tan devaluado
bueno el rublo salto hasta 160 en estos
momentos está cotizando en 105 se ha
apreciado bastante en estas últimas
semanas pasó el shock pero se ha
evaluado más del 30 por ciento en este
año esto va a traer
una cifra de inflación muy alta para
rusia la cual la ubicamos por arriba del
20 por ciento y una caída del pib entre
7 y 9 por ciento esto golpea al bolsillo
de los rusos que ya vieron limitadas sus
posibilidades de extraer dólares o bien
de comprar otras divisas en los bancos